we can let this week pass us by without
diving
into the history of an iconic trend that
we all know and love
this one isn't on our face but let us
point out
some fun facts about the history of
nail polish and nails in this really
awesome beauty backgrounder
[Music]
long before gel manicures and acrylics
warriors an ancient babylonia would
groom and
decorate their nails before entering
battle in 3200
bc the warriors painted their nails
black with
coal and tinted their lips to match
in 1878 the first nail salon was
opened by mary e cobb in new york city
mary went on to invent the emery board
and
expanded her nail salon business across
the u.s
and produced her own line of cosmetics
and nail care products
all while being a single mother we bowed
down to this
nail maven the invention of the modern
day liquid
polish is thanks in part to the boom of
the automobile
industry at the turn of the 20th century
makeup artist
michelle menard created a glossy nail
lacquer
that mimicked the shine on cars and
would eventually help
launch the brand revlon to fame
and prominence acrylic nails were
invented by a dentist
named fredrick slack in 1957.
he broke a nail at work and used
aluminum foil
and dental acrylic to fix it his
faux nail looked so real that he
eventually patented his invention
decorating our nails has been a source
of expression and beauty for more than
5 000 years today we see all kinds of
amazing and intricate nail art
we love our long acrylic prison nails
and getting to paint with all the colors
we can imagine
thanks to the ancient babylonians who
painted the way
for all of us wasn't that fascinating we
love our beauty backgrounders
around here but this one really felt
extra informative and before we start
on decorating our nails i wanted to show
some love
to a product that i came across recently
it's the bellasonic
electric nail file and it's sold on qvc
it has all these different attachments
so you can
file you can buff here's the even cooler
part
you can put the one and do your heel
i mean this little thing does everything
um and it's sold on qvc and it's
definitely
a very unique tool that i've come across
okay now it is so important to give
yourself a little tlc and pampering
at home when you can um but
i will say i just got to paint my nails
and it boosted my mood like nobody's
business
and here to help us with some nail
polish tricks is
friend of the show and editor-in-chief
of allure magazine the beauty bible
it's michelle lee hi everyone hey drew
hi michelle how are you i'm good i feel
like i have to try that tool
it just does it all i love it um
okay now you have a nail design
um that we can all do at home is this
true
i do so i'm gonna show everyone how to
do one of my favorite
nail hacks um so drew i don't know if
you have any of these hole punch
stickers at home but these are for
anyone who uses a binder typically we'd
have these like whole
reinforcement stickers around they're
super cheap at just like office supply
stores
okay are we ready drew oh yeah i'm ready
okay so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take scissors
and we're gonna snip one side of these
towards the center of the hole
so what that's gonna do is it's just
gonna open up that circle
so that then when we position it on our
hands that's going to be great
okay so what we want to do is we want to
create this little half moon shape at
the bottom and that's going to create
negative space at the bottom so i'm
going to position the little sticker
right in the center okay so the other
trick that i learned from some of my
nail artist friends is that you never
shake a bottle of polish what you want
to do
instead because if you shake it you're
going to get bubbles so what you do is
you roll it
in your hands like this and that's the
way that you shake a bottle
i've never heard that
yep yeah i feel like i shake everything
oh see there i go okay so what you do is
you're gonna put the nail polish
on anything above that sticker and then
you just want to
after it's dried a little bit you just
peel off that sticker
and then it reveals this little half
moon shape and so
you know sometimes the the line there is
not going to be fantastic
and clean and what i like to do also is
you can just take a little
makeup brush and you can just dip that
into some nail polish remover and then
you can just clean
up any of that area and it's just a
really easy thing to do
you have no idea the hot mess i have
made
michelle
okay well michelle
[Laughter]
i don't know i i think you're gonna have
to sell this one
um well oh darn it um oh
gosh hi michelle this is ridiculous
um i just filled the nail polish remover
all over the desk
if you're looking to remove the paint
off your desk
follow me and if you're looking for the
most beautiful nail art
there really is you have to check out
michelle's instagram
don't follow me and i can't wait till
our next adventure michelle you're the
[Music]
best
you